Haley’s Comet
and Mark Twain’s Prediction
In 1909, Samuel Clemens—known by his pen
name, Mark Twain—said,
I came in with Halley’s Comet in 1835.
It is coming again next year, and I expect
to go out with it.
It will be the greatest disappointment of
my life if I don’t go out with Halley’s
Comet.
The Almighty has said, no doubt: ‘Now here
are these two unaccountable freaks; they came
in together, they must go out together.
Clemens was indeed born just after Halley’s
Comet appeared in 1835, and, true to his prediction,
he died of a heart attack one day after it
appeared at its brightest in 1910.
While this association, combined with Clemens’
foretelling of his own death, is probably
unique, Halley’s Comet has been the subject
of a string of predictions since 1705.
That was the year that Sir Edmond Halley first
realized that comets sighted in 1531, 1607,
and 1682 were all the same comet.
In his A Synopsis of the Astronomy of Comets,
Halley stated that the comets all appeared
very similar in their orbit and various other
parameters.
From his conclusion, he calculated that it
would reappear in 1758.
Halley died before he was able to see his
prediction come true.
As reliable as ever, the comet appeared late
that year and reached perihelion—when it
emerged from the far side of the Sun—in
1759.
The comet was named “Halley’s Comet”
in honour of the man who had discovered its
pattern.
Because of its orbit, Halley’s Comet always
shows up around every 76 years, just as Halley
calculated.
However, due to the gravitational pull of
the planets that it passes, it’s sometimes
a year or two off the mark.
After the find, scientists began to calculate
when Halley’s Comet appeared in the past,
while trying to account for the slight deviation.
The dates they came up with matched up with
a surprising number of recorded comet sightings
in history.
The oldest commonly accepted date for the
first documented reference of Halley’s Comet
is 240 B.C., when it was sighted by Chinese
astronomers.
The passing of the comet was recorded in Shih
Chi and Wen Hsien Thung Khao chronicles.
However, it’s possible that it could be
the comet observed in Greece as far back as
467 B.C., making it the earliest known recorded
sighting.
Back then, no one thought to keep track of
the time between comets to see if one might
be recurring.
Comets were seen as isolated events and a
sort of herald of change or disaster.
As Shakespeare wrote in Julius Caesar around
1600: “When beggars die there are no comets
seen; The heavens themselves blaze forth the
death of princes.”
(Interestingly, Halley’s Comet would have
passed in Caesar’s lifetime around 87 B.C.—two
years before his father died and Caesar became
the head of his family).
The comet has, in fact, been at the centre
of a few historical events.
For instance, William the Conqueror took the
comet as a good omen when it showed up just
before the 1066 invasion of England.
The comet was memorialized on the massive
Bayeux Tapestry which was made after the invasion.
The tapestry shows people celebrating the
crowning of King Harold, terrified of the
comet soaring above.
Below King Harold is a fleet of ships, hinting
at the coming Norman Conquest.
We can be fairly certain that the 1066 comet
was indeed Halley’s Comet because of one
Eilmer of Malmesbury.
Eilmer was a monk born around 980 AD who was
able to see the comet twice in his lifetime.
The first was in 989, and he had a feeling
it was a bad omen; soon after its appearance,
his town was attacked by the Danes.
He lived to see the comet again in 1066 and
it appears that Eilmer, at least, saw the
correlation between the 989 comet and the
1066 comet.
However, others didn’t pick up on the pattern
until Halley in 1705.
Writing following the comet’s second appearance,
Eilmer said:
“You’ve come, have you?
… You’ve come, you source of tears to
many mothers, you evil.
I hate you!
It is long since I saw you; but as I see you
now you are much more terrible, for I see
you brandishing the downfall of my country.
I hate you!”
In 1222, the comet passed by Earth again,
heralding similar doom.
This time, Genghis Khan started marching west.
Apparently, he thought of the comet, which
was heading west the same as he did, as his
personal star.
Of course, the invasion of Europe would leave
millions of people dead—not such a great
omen for them.
Fast forward back to 1910.
The death of Clemens was, of course, a sad
event for the literary world, but the year
could be seen as an omen ushering in a new
age on Earth.
That year, the first photograph was taken
of Halley’s Comet, pictured in the show
notes, and between that sighting and the next
in 1986, mankind would advance technologically
in wondrous ways, far more rapidly than at
any other known time in our history.
Of course, we also waged war among ourselves
at a baffling scale a couple times,and even
came extremely close to possibly destroying
most of the life on Earth.
On the flip-side, around the same time we
were nearly destroying ourselves- illustrating
the need for humans to spread out among the
heavens- we took our first steps away from
this giant space vessel known as Earth.
Further, for one all too brief moment, humanity
was united in 1969 as we watched the first
human step out onto the surface of the Moon.
When Halley’s comet arrived again in 1986,
the first observation of the comet from space
was made.
This turned out to be fortunate, because the
view from Earth was very disappointing.
In fact, according to a study published in
the Royal Astronomical Society of Canada Journal,
the 1986 view of the comet was the worst in
about 2,000 years.
This was compounded by the fact that light
pollution made it impossible for many to see
it even with binoculars.
However, the “Halley’s Armada,” as the
“fleet” of spaceships sent up to observe
the comet from space was called, was able
to snap good quality pictures of the comet,
even capturing pictures of its nucleus.
On the advances, NASA commented: “It was
inevitable that this most famous of all comets
would receive unprecedented attention, but
the actual magnitude of the effort has surprised
even most of those involved in it.”
Unfortunately, NASA itself suffered a tragedy
in attempting to view Halley’s Comet from
space.
Part of the mission of the ill-fated Challenger
was to observe the comet, but of course it
suffered a rocket malfunction and exploded
just minutes after take-off, killing everyone
on board.
The next time Halley’s Comet will swing
by Earth is in 2061, being at its brightest
in July of that year.
Thankfully, it is expected that it will be
much brighter than in 1986.
Perhaps by that time, if you’re still around,
you’ll be able to view it from, say, an
orbiting resort or from the Moon.
Who knows?
You may even be able to see it at a completely
different date from a colony on Mars or taking
a ship out to meet it.